y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa
apple y google enfrentan en nuevos
señalamientos por presuntas acciones
monopolísticas esta vez por parte de la
desarrolladora del popular videojuego
fort night la disputa hizo que estas dos
compañías la vetaran de su tienda de
aplicaciones afectando a millones de
usuarios que hay detrás de estas medidas
y qué implicaciones tienen empezamos
la nueva temporada del famoso videojuego
force night ya está disponible pero los
usuarios de los sistemas operativos ios
y android no podrán encontrarla en sus
respectivas tiendas de aplicaciones
apple y google decidieron que la app ya
no va más
todo empezó a mitades de agosto cuando
epic games dueña de fort night habilitó
un nuevo sistema de pagos en la
aplicación los jugadores ahora tenían la
opción de hacer compras directamente con
epic y a un menor precio del que
tendrían que pagar a través de apple o
google con esta nueva modalidad la
desarrolladora buscaba evadir la
comisión de hasta el 30 por ciento que
estas compañías cobran sobre las
transacciones que se realizan en sus
tiendas de aplicaciones las dos gigantes
tecnológicas no se quedaron de brazos
cruzados y argumentando una violación de
sus políticas se eliminaron a fort night
de sus respectivas tiendas
eso significa que quienes deseen
instalar for night en sus dispositivos
ya no podrán encontrarla en el appstore
o en google play sin embargo si ya la
tenían instalada pueden seguir
utilizándola al menos por ahora aunque
no tendrán acceso a sus actualizaciones
para los usuarios de android existen
opciones este sistema operativo permite
que se descarguen e instalen
aplicaciones desde múltiples tiendas for
night puede ser obtenida directamente
desde la página web de epic games por
ejemplo pero no pasa lo mismo con apple
que tiene un ecosistema cerrado para que
un software sea instalado en un ipad por
ejemplo tiene que estar disponible en el
app store y por ende aprobado por actual
había epic games anticipado la reacción
de estas dos compañías solo un par de
horas después de que ford night fue
eliminada de cada una de las tiendas
epic presentó demandas primero una de 65
páginas contra apple alegando que así es
como mantiene su monopolio luego
presentó otras 60 páginas contra google
pero la situación tuvo mayor
trascendencia con el fabricante del
iphone apple le dio a epi 14 días para
corregir el sistema de pagos de four
night o le cancelaría su cuenta de
desarrollador el plazo se venció y las
aplicaciones de epic games ya no están
disponibles en app store la medida no
afecta auriol engine una herramienta
utilizada por varias compañías para
desarrollar los gráficos en sus
videojuegos una decisión judicial había
prohibido que a paul a bloquear el fallo
busca evitar un daño colateral entre los
usuarios de wii a beijing entre ellos
microsoft que salió a la defensa de epic
se espera que ambas compañías se reúnan
en una audiencia programada para el 28
de septiembre paralelamente a las
medidas legales epic desplegó a través
de internet toda una estructura de
campaña contra la imagen de apple
a la que tituló free for night o liberen
a for night enmarcada en la disputa
lanzó un torneo llamado free for night
of a través del cual parodiaba el logo
de apple el personaje principal de esta
competencia fue llamado dark tide con un
magnate malvado usando un traje y una
cabeza de manzana epic también recreó el
famoso comercial de apos de 1984 a
través del cual anunció el lanzamiento
de su macintosh
allí desafiaba la compañía ibm que por
entonces dominaba el mercado de la
informática que la presentaba como un
dictador la pieza estaba inspirada en la
novela 1984 de george orwell ahora en la
versión de epic games apple es
presentado como el gran hermano
desde junio de pica había solicitado
tener una tienda de aplicaciones dentro
de la tienda de aplicaciones de apple
pero ésta rechazó la oferta ya sea este
o no el motivo de la discordia durante
los últimos años a paul ha sido señalada
por llevar políticas monopolísticas y
por limitar injustamente a sus rivales
empresas como spotify se han quejado de
tener que pagar a apple hasta un 30% por
cada venta hecha a través de su app
store por conductas como éstas la unión
europea y eeuu abrieron investigaciones
en su contra en 2018 netflix dejó de
ofrecer suscripciones a través de webs
para no tener que pagar dicha comisión a
paul ha defendido este cobro
comparándolo con las tarifas impuestas
por los minoristas otras víctor hugo y
amazon por ejemplo funcionan igual que
los medios de comunicación se han
lanzado a pronosticar que resultará de
todo esto un análisis del portal
business insider recordó que esta no es
la primera vez que for night presiona a
un gigante tecnológico para que cambien
sus reglas y que la última vez que lo
hizo funciona
el portal rescata que en 2018 son y no
permitía el juego cruzado de for night
es decir que un usuario de playstation
pudiera jugar en tiempo real con un
usuario de xbox o nintendo la presión
fue tanta que son y terminó cediendo the
wall street journal advierte que la
disputa podría costar más que los
honorarios legales agrega que según
reportes el mes pasado el videojuego
generó alrededor de 52.5 millones de
dólares en compras que se hicieron en la
aplicación a través de app store y
google play for night llegó a ser el
videojuego más popular del mundo y a
junio de 2020 contaba con más de 350
millones de usuarios a nivel global
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
74 puntocom
[Música]